i'm cheryl hickey from et canada nice to
see you you too
listen i am obsessed with bomb bomb i
know you wrote this with ed sheeran over
the world's best burritos which then
makes me want to ask you what kind of
burrito girl are you is it all the
toppings or just a few of the toppings
for me
it's i'm not like a um
after lunch burrito person like i don't
want like the rice and beans stuff but
i'm like a breakfast burrito person
okay so i like breakfast burritos i like
like
you know some egg i've had like a
plant-based burrito that's really good i
love salsa verde that's like my favorite
so i'm a breakfast burrito person it's
it's like i just feel like they're the
best kind of burritos i'm not into like
the lunch burritos
okay i love that i know ed sheeran talks
a lot about bouncing his ideas off
friends like taylor swift and who do you
bounce ideas off of for a song like bom
bom
hmm
[Music]
honestly i mean i play it for a couple
friends but
i don't really play my music like out
loud that much to people because
okay i just feel like the most important
thing is that i like it and like
everybody's taste is so subjective like
yeah
that people could just like
bum me out and be like i don't really
get it
and
i don't really care because if i get it
then and i want to sing it over and over
then i just don't want you to bum me out
yeah so you're you're listening to your
own internal monologue i listen to my
own internal one yeah and i find for me
like
sometimes i'll listen to a song and be
like wow i i like to keep it between me
and my collaborators so
it's not like i don't get other opinions
but it's people that are like already
working on the project with me
yeah i get that hearing uh this song on
this album there's a lot of um raw and
personal moments in the music especially
you know finding the positive and a
negative are you ever hesitant to put um
too much of yourself out there in your
music of course
all the time it's like you are it's the
worst it's like literally the worst i'm
always like
talking to my therapist about it like is
this okay should i not believe it
um yeah it's hard because it's also
that's the kind of writing that excites
me the most like when i read like a
sally rooney novel it's so
detailed and like that's what i love
about it because i think it's so much
more powerful to
it's the same reason i love like taylor
swift song so much it's so much more
powerful to be like
i don't know like
whatever
i'm missing like i can't remember lyric
that she says now but like
when she's like you left your cigarette
on the table as opposed to being like
you made me sad that night like i just
think yeah the detail is more powerful
than just saying the blanket emotion and
i feel like i really discovered that
about
myself as a writer especially this album
like i was like oh yeah because before i
would do the more big emotions like
oh my god like you know
it's you and i'm kissing you it's crazy
and whatever but
i think now more and more like i think
the details just tell more of a story so
that is that can be very exposing and
yeah and complicated it's hard
i think it's really great for your fans
and your listeners also though because
we can you can you can dive into that
space and really sort of understand or
try to understand certainly where you're
coming from and then see yourself in the
music as well
totally i mean that's like what taylor
swift has always said she's like
people you know she was she said
something once in an interview that i
saw where she was like
i used to be afraid that if i was
writing such detailed songs that people
wouldn't relate but it's the fact that
it's so detailed that actually makes
people relate because it's yes it's like
real you know so that is what turns me
on about songwriting and at the same
time
can be
really hard you know to do terrifying
i'm sure yeah for sure you also
collaborated with willow on this album
on psycho freak she's incredible what
was your energy like together
i feel like we're both just so
like
because i feel like we
have a lot of the same intentions and
goals which is
less about i guess like you know
commercial success and more about
personal
growth and like you know pers like
growth as just human beings like we're
so vulnerable
with each other like
i'll be like what are you doing today
and she'll be like trying not to have a
breakdown how about you and i'm like
yeah
nice i get that
um
so
it's cool that
you know we get to
i don't know i feel very like
safe in her
energy um and it's been like so fun to
spend time with her because i always
wanted to hang out with her and
and also getting to see her in the
studio was like amazing because she
all the kind of like background vocals
like these parts that she wrote
for the song like i just got to see her
in her element just headphones on mike
just doing it and i was just like
that is so sick she is so
like musically gifted
that's amazing last time we saw you was
in los angeles and i remember you were
really excited because you just bought
your family a house in miami what does
it feel like to be able to have that
kind of success to do things for your
parents and people you love and and for
yourself now
i mean literally amazing i feel
so so fortunate
like i'm just i'm so thankful
yeah it's a beautiful thing you've
created well congratulations on the
album on everything
and for the music thank you so much